We Begin this hour with a new Memoir by
award-winning actor and comedian Rob
Delaney now he is known for a sharp and
satiric comedy but his latest book could
be his most personal and honest work yet
a heart that works details the brain
tumor diagnosis of Delaney's
one-year-old son Henry and its emotional
impact on his family Henry died in 2018.
Delaney writes quote I genuinely believe
whether it's true or not that if people
felt a fraction of what my family felt
and still feels they would know what
this life and this world are really
about he says he hopes the Memoir will
show us how Grace may appear in even the
darkest of Times Robert Laney joins us
now good morning how you doing I'm okay
thank you thanks for having me of course
now a heart that works it's a music
lyric but also a personal philosophy
tell us about that title yeah so
um a heart that works that's the second
half of a quote which is a heart that
hurts is a heart that works
and I think you know that's I should say
that's from a very beautiful song called
Universal Heartbeat by Julianna Hatfield
and um yeah it is one of my major life
philosophies because if your heart is
hurting it's working and if you are born
into one of these here bodies that's
going to happen and so you can't hate it
you have to feel it and live it and so
that's been a very helpful quote an idea
for me there's so many things that a
reader can take away but what do you
personally want them to take away
what do I want them to take away uh some
some comfort some understanding some
love I started the book in a very angry
frame of mind
um an editor in the UK you asked me to
write the book I wasn't thinking you
know what the world needs another book
from me but and I got a wonderful letter
from this editor who had nursed her
father through a brain tumor and death
when she was a child and so I was like
yeah you want a book you want a book
about my son and his brain tumor and
death so I wrote some very angry stuff
and sent it to her and I said is that
you sure and she wrote it everybody else
to feel yeah and she wrote back and she
said yes that is what I want and I was
like oh uh okay so then I wrote the book
and and I went through a real
transformation from anger
to really more Love by the end of it
there's still anger I'm human and of
course not perfect but uh it was a very
educational Journey for me it felt good
to write I I think journey is a word Rob
number one it's beautifully done I mean
you really take us through the process
sort of step by step I think in a very
painful and poignant way it started with
Henry he's won and he starts throwing up
yeah and then you go through several
diagnosis yeah and then you're told he
has a brain tumor the size of an apple
yeah his little head and his tiny little
head yeah and so when you get that news
what do you think you think you don't
think he's going to die
right you think uh well well frankly
unfortunately you do entertain the
possibility because it's a very real one
yeah and it is what happened but he's
being treated and so you do have
something yeah you think we're going to
do this stuff we're gonna of course
we're gonna study we're gonna become
experts and brain tumors and we love
them and and so it'll be hard but yeah
we'll we'll win you know and he'll live
but that isn't what happened and that's
often not what happens in situations
like this so that was another reason to
write the book is to give people you
know a realistic picture of the things
that can happen in this life you also
have two other young boys you said at
one point you had three boys under the
age of five and the thing that really
got to me was you said it's so important
to not put family responsibilities on
pause yeah because you have these two
other beautiful creatures that you have
to talk to and and engage with you said
you have to make the decision you all
made the decision to protect your
marriage you even talk about having sex
with your wife during a very I'm not
trying to be inappropriate here but it
struck me because we think God in the
middle of all of this everything has to
stop yeah but you're saying no you have
to love you have to touch you have to
feel why did you want to include that it
seems very important to me uh well first
I want to say did you guys hear that
I've had sex
well I could tell by that actually right
you know so you're still able to put it
but no you're right and it's funny
because in the first draft
um if there's any aspiring writers here
I'd like to say you know sometimes you
hear the phrase you can't polish a turd
yes you really can my first drafts are
terrible and then I Polish Polish Polish
and then sometimes they turn out okay
but in the first draft I was like I'm
gonna say everything and then I'll
remove some stuff and I showed it to my
wife who's a wonderful reader and and
and uh really helpful with this book but
uh I said I'll take that out and she
said I don't think that you should
because it's true we did he had a
13-hour surgery during which we got a
little hotel room right next to the
hospital and uh we had sex because we
were scared and we were holding each
other and um we're both of age that's an
intimate connection yes and so and but
then a lot of people have thanked me for
putting that in there bereaved parents
parents who have kids in the hospital
and stuff so I was like okay all right
how do you tell your other children
though how do you explain were you going
to ask no no yeah I was thinking that
too how do you well I'll tell you
exactly how uh they see us crying after
we learn that the tumor has returned
they say why are you crying and and we
tell them
Henry's cancer has returned
what's going to happen and then we told
those little boys we said he's going to
die yeah the cancer is going to spread
and there's nothing they can do now and
it it's going to kill him and uh and
then because they're kids they ask again
and again and again
um which we kind of do in our own heads
as adults we have to repeat these things
we don't believe them kids do it out
loud
which is beautiful
and um so they knew they knew everything
there was you can't protect them from
that but you you taught you're talking
about crying and you're where you have
humor still but you cried while writing
this book oh certainly yeah what's it
like though to relive it at this table
when you're going to be talking to
audiences right who are at book tours
that coming to see you what's that like
first I'd like to say uh Gail you came
in this morning and started talking to
me in the Green Room about the book and
you were crying and you hugged me and
you asked me a very specific questions
and you had a very beautiful human
response that which I was not expecting
because I've been talking about you in
the book all morning yeah and something
about honest to God looking you in your
face talking
talking about the death of your little
boy yeah it just and I think everybody
puts their selves in that position yeah
I don't have a little baby yeah
um but I have a grandchild and I think
everybody starts thinking about that and
then I see you say God but you did that
and that was that was the best thing
that's happened to me in the last thing
because you had a gender in yourself I
don't want people to perfunctorally ask
me you know things and say like oh
you're tragedy and then move on I want
them to cry my boy is dead I won't hold
him again I hold him in my heart and I
think about them all the time but you
had a response like that and that was
like water to me in the desert so that
was beautiful so that's how I want to
talk about him yeah so that's how I do
it is hopefully every fifth interview I
do somebody like you will do something
beautiful and real and then I feel human
and heard is human and you always say
that you know when people say everything
happens for a reason I love what you
said some and he uses the a word will
say everything happens for a reason you
said listen I just want to die so I can
go and kick God in the teeth that's how
you put it yeah I mean to say that
that's not comforting when you hear
things like that what is comforting what
is comforting to you well I just laughed
when you said that silly thing that I
said like like after Henry died I wanted
to make sure that I lived to 97 and then
died an old withered man and I wanted to
cross the finish line of life and then
meet God and kick his teeth in yeah
that's how I felt you know I don't feel
that way now five years on but I felt
that way then why wouldn't I a lot of
people feel that way yeah and that's and
you have to go through all those
feelings they're they're there for a
reason no there were so many things you
said you don't think of beating and
fighting cancer because cancer is going
to do what it wants to do despite all
the treatment just yeah if it happens to
you go for the ride and you said in this
is my favorite well one of my in between
Harry's birth and Henry's in between
Henry's birth and death was his life
yeah that's your favorite part oh yeah
so you you think you talk about Henry's
big blue eyes what do you miss most
about this little creature that you have
well certainly his eyes and I would
submit I mean look I can't be objective
about it but his eyes were like dark
blue and light blue I mean they were
weird and beautiful and big and it makes
me very angry that you can't look at
them that I didn't that he's not in
there right now after this I wish this
book was about Falcons and that after
this you would go into the green room
and he was there and you could meet him
and look at those eyes and you can't and
that is offensive to me and you know and
you could smell him and hold them and
you would knock something over you'd get
something on your pretty pink dress and
you have to go change and you'd be like
Henry that's what I wish no I I thank
you for for sharing this story for
sharing his life with us and how you and
your wife got through it and you had
another baby we did was that a difficult
decision to make because you said Leo
was pregnant at his funeral yeah
um you know we wanted to have another
kid because we just love kids now our
youngest is four that's like old how
come I want more babies we can't we're
not going to but
um
yeah he would and I should say um um our
youngest Teddy was born in the same room
that Henry died in um yeah he died yeah
Henry died on my birthday too yeah it
was just one gut punch yes so many
layers nobody should read this book
thank you for your transition yes it's
rare that people write a book let alone
right I'm on TV and open up themselves
like that so thank you we appreciate you
rob DeLand we do appreciate yes that
works is on sale today